would you live somewhere if the central
mission of the state is to make death
optional while I often on this channel
talk about the scientists who are
working on finding genes molecules and
mechanisms that underpin the aging
process and yes being a scientist I know
how important that is there is also much
that goes on behind the scenes that I
never get to talk about as I only tend
to talk about the latest findings now
earlier this year I experienced this
firsthand when I ended Susu an
experimental co- living project that
brought together people with backgrounds
in crypto AI safety Network States
decentralized science and Longevity I
attended to help educate on the
longevity side while I attended for just
over a week many more stayed for 1 to
two months the idea being that this
duration a number of people falls out
sweet spots as falic butan writes in his
blog post a 4-day conference is a break
from your life but a two month dat is
your life and for at least some people
it turned out that the small but highly
focused Network effect of a few hundred
people who care about the precise thing
you care about really can substitute the
massive but much more unfocused Network
effects of the global mega
cities so susali was an example of what
can be referred to as Network States
Network states are a relatively new
Concepts and have yet to be established
on a large scale but they offer the
potential for individuals to come
together and form community ities based
on shared interests and values without
being limited by geographical boundaries
the concept of network States was first
proposed by BAGI sasen an entrepreneur
and investor in the technology industry
Now The Next Step Up is falia a fatalia
is a movement to start a longevity
Network State built around the idea that
life is good death is bad the movement
aims to create a new kind of society
that is focused on extending human
lifespan and improving the quality of
life for everyone so that's what it is
but why exactly do we need it and what
really happens at these popup cities
well fatalia is pitched as a city that
builds longevity companies and develops
longevity Therapeutics but having spoken
to the two co-founders Lawrence ion who
is also a founding Steward or fadal and
co-organized sus Alle with falic as well
as speaking with Nicholas anzinger
founder of infin VC as an influencer of
network States here is what they
Envision for
falia falia between January 6 and March
1st on the Caribbean island of
ratan uh where we have a more aligned
Society um that is really prioritizing
this mission of making death
optional um and is excited to create the
sandbox where we're trying a better
regulatory framework where not only we
we have healthy co- living uh and and
co-working collaboration but we also
have I've seen three initiatives already
for clinical trials that will be run
during these two months by the people
that are there we'll have entrepreneurs
artists scientists
innovators we really uh filter for
Builders so why exactly are they
focusing on longevity how can you solve
for the problems that the FDA is
creating right the timelines that drugs
um take 10 years to go to market and
cost hundreds of millions or even
billions of dollars what is the
entrepreneurial project that you can do
to overcome this I didn't have an answer
until I found out about prospera and
about Charter cities and about sort of
the possibility to do special economic
zones that have different legal rules
right so I've became um I've started a
VC fund based in Prosper because there
was already Innovation going on in this
specific Zone a Zone Zone that's located
in ratan Honduras and has in my opinion
the most advanced legal system in the
world that allows for innovation in a
whole lot of sectors in technology so I
went out there uh aiming starting a VC
fund aiming to attract um startups that
can gain advantages from that and my
hint was startups that were already
there right so there was already a
construction Tech startup there a drone
startup so you can do things in the
physical world that are otherwise not
posable there was already a bank there
and there were already there was already
a crypto Community here um so again
crypto is something that's very over
regulated which is what these zones
could be an advantage for um but the one
thing that really clicked was longevity
and biotech so there's a company here
called minicircle that does um that
developed photo stat and gene therapy
and did stage one clinical trials here
on the island with a very reputed
American doctor U perfectly
interoperable with other jurisdictions
and they did that in um for much lower
cost and with the possibility to do
medical tourism so I went out to the
world with that story and it just seemed
to resonate extremely well with Lawrence
and with the design longevity community
so as soon as Lawrence invited me and we
started doing meetings together we had
like hundreds of people pop up right so
this is kind of where I saw the
strongest Market fit and need and in the
process I also learned about longevity
and how important it is like hey if you
pull this off um what we've been finding
in science and technology what could be
possible this is the most important
mission in the world to make death
optional so that's how I got really
excited and that's how I got to uh start
this company together with Lawrence but
who can actually come to fatalia
initially we want to optimize for trust
and for ensuring that we have the right
kind of community and this is first and
foremost um that we select for very
ethical people right so people people
who um can like think for themselves and
who do the right thing when nobody's
looking we're looking for people that
are generally helpful to each other they
don't expect like Resort tourism or
whatever right if they see a problem in
the neighborhood in the community they
fix it we also selecting for people that
are that can build right so and they
don't just talk right so we're in a
Frontier Tech space and we need to do a
lot of fundraising and a lot of Shilling
um but we we try to select for people
that can also then just build things in
the real world so we have this very
clear profile and then we have Val
values around sort of you know self-
responsibility a very strong informed
consent right so in giving each other
space and valuing each other's
Independence um so so this is kind of
the profile we select for and then you
know you should have a background in one
of the um the things we care about right
so you don't so so longevity in biotech
both from from the science and from the
business side is highly um valued um to
come here same for crypto and dii right
also healthc Care Professionals right so
we also need to deliver these treatments
into the human body so we're encouraging
Innovative healthc Care Professionals to
join as well but as's also other
Frontier Technologies like legal
engineering for example or if you have a
background in media and in content or in
philosophy which would you see as highly
aligned with what we're doing we
encourage people with a broad skill set
um and high alignment to to come to
Vitalia uh and also we are able to give
financial assistance so we want to make
it affordable also for students or young
or recent graduates or early stage
entrepreneurs or um people from um
lesser developed countries with lower
income to come right so we will make
this possible to come based on
background um if we see a fit with the
values of the the community and um
ability to contribute to to this
endeavor right so similar to The
Manhattan Project you know the Manhattan
Project also selected you know people
who were capable of contributing to that
mission so this is also um what Ralia
will select for but Vitalia has much
bigger plans than just the event being
planned to start next year so Vitalia is
really just a beginning to um what we
want to build which will be uh Network
Society
with hubs in three to five different
locations right so prospera we see as
the best candidate for the first one but
we going to be Community Driven right so
when having decided that this is where
we built the first district we're
inviting the community to see it for
themselves to experiment to play and to
work together right so that's what
Italia has set up for right so we want
to provide um we want to bring this
community together we're helping and
putting together housing we're creating
the space and we're creating uh a
schedule and agenda um that's kind of
basic and that others can build on top
of of right so we'll do education and
events around longevity AI crypto all
different tier Technologies we need to
pull this off if there's a will there's
a way right if the will of the people
says that Co is a crisis and we need to
move at warp speed we do it right we did
the we made the covid vaccines in
up to 8 months we could have done it in
in four and we as a community not not
everyone agrees that aging is a crisis
but some people can coordinate in one
place and say look this is the most
important Endeavor and we should move at
workp speed and
who who are they outside to tell us what
we can and cannot do with our own bodies
right we can set our own rules and
regulations in this location at least or
this network of
locations um or at least in some of
those locations right where we can speed
up Innovation and and Drug development
especially for longevity especially
because it's not considered a disease
and there isn't an easy pathway through
the regulatory process if you are
interested in learning more then fatalia
has a website with more information like
want to give people that experience of
we're really building a city or a
district to
together